صباح الانوار من مدينه شواش من بيشه
التونسيه مدينه السكر والمخارق والحلويات
اللذيذه هنا هذا ليس مصباح علاء الدين
السحري هو مصباح السيد عبد الفتاح الشواشي
هذه تقريبا اكبر قطه
المصباح الزيتي الذي هو على شكل نعم امامك
مصباح علاء الدين
صباح الخير امامك مصباح علاء الدين السحري
شو امنيه
عم بهذا المصباح احكي لنا اياها مباشره
على الهواء
[موسيقى]
الامنيه هو ان يتحسن حال تونس اول امنيه
هو ان تخرج البلاد بلاد بلادي تونس من
ربما الازمه التي تلمبها الان قليلا لكن
لدينا ايضا امنيات جميله كان يعم السلام
العالم وان ربما تكون كل الشعوب تعيش
بسلام بمحبه ووئام عن طريق هذا المصباح
الجميل الذي لا يعرف
علاء الدين السحري املاك كذلك اتمنى لكم
كل الصحه والحب
صباحات صباح العربيه الجميله والجميله
دائما هناك اعزائي متحف جميل وجميل جدا
انا بالفعل افخر لان توجد في تونس
ربما يعني اماكن بهذا الجمال وبهذه
العلاقه والحضاره بهذا المجهود الجبار
الذي عبد الستار هذه تقريبا اقدم قطعه
يتجاوز عمرها القرنين من الزمن مصباح زيتي
جميل وقيم وقيم جدا هنا في صفحه جبل جميل
نجد هذا المتحف الجميل سي عبد الفتاح
الشواشي تتفضل معي سي عبد الستار هنا همم
سيد عبد الستار الشواشي حارس الذاكره في
مدينه شواش التونسيه كيف يتبادلت لك هذه
الفكره التي عبد الفتاح
متقاعد منه وزاره الفلاحه انا همم قررت
اني اعمل حاجه يعني بالنسبه لنا دوله
قراتني همم خدمت فيها عملت فيها قلت نعم
حاجه اللي ما عملتها الدوله نعملها انا
ذاكره الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
اربعه مجموعات تقريبا 160 مجموعه يعني
المجموعه بتبدا من ثلاثه تبدا حتى ال 20
التاريخ الزراعي كذلك في حضره التاريخ
المنزلي بحضره التاريخ اللي اللباس ايضا
لانه هناك مفروشات وملابس تقريبا لم نعد
نراها اليوم في تونس التي عبد الستار كم
كلفك هذا المنجز كم كلفتك هذه المهمه
الصعبه التي اليت على نفسك ان تحفظ بها
التاريخ وان تحفظ بها ثقافه
عليك كل انسان مغروم بحاجه ما يحسش
المصروف ولا الفلوس
[موسيقى]
ياتون الى هنا
عند المدارس الابتدائيه والمدارس الثانويه
اللي في ولايه الباب جيو يعملوا دروس عندي
مره سفاره بتاع فرنسا يعني جابت
هوني عندي مجموعات يجوني من كم الجمهوريه
عندي
سواحي جوني من فرنسا من الامارات العربيه
المتحده يعني بالنسبه
تبعين الناس كلها فرحانه به واولاد بلادي
فرحانين
بيعاونوني يعني حتى ما عندي حتى اشكاليه
يعني
ممتاز ايه ده انت عبد الستار يقول بان
الزوار يتوافدون من داخل تونس ومن خارجها
بالفعل نحن هنا في مكان مهم واا مهم جدا
همم في الحقيقه يثير الاعجاب وكذلك يثير
التقدير لرجل منح حياته من اجل ان اا يؤسس
هذا المتحف الرائع سي عبد الستار يقول بان
الدوله التونسيه قدمت له الكثير درسته
ورعته وانشات فهو يريد ان يقدم شيء للدوله
التونسيه وكذلك للشعوب الشعوب التونسي
وغيره ميناء الزوار ويقول بانه سوف يواصل
في هذه المهمه رغم المبالغ المغريه
اصدقائي واعزائي الذي اتم اقتراحها عليه